so today is one of the wackiest days
in politics that i can remember and
it's a damn good thing i've got my new
mic and it's finally
tuned beautifully from the standpoint of
audio
because we have a lot to talk about
today and donald trump has called
a sudden news conference he initially
seemed to be trying to gather
the press corps as
barack obama was speaking at john
lewis's funeral today clearly he
couldn't take the fact that he wasn't
invited
and bill clinton spoke and george w bush
spoke and barack obama spoke beautifully
for 40 minutes
and so donald trump uh the white house
press corps you can check out caitlin
collins's tweet in fact let's see if we
can even pull it up
um let's see here
she tweeted earlier where was this
exactly
wow she's tweeted a lot okay here it is
the white house this was at 104 pm
eastern the white house press pool was
just abruptly called together president
trump has nothing on his schedule for an
another 90 minutes then paula reed
from cbs paula reed cbs
tweeted where was that justin president
trump announces 5 30 pm press conference
so first of all he was already on tilt
today
because john lewis 32 reduction in gdp
annualized from the second quarter the
worst numbers ever i mean just ever ever
ever ever ever you understand what i'm
saying uh
right and um then donald trump floated
the idea of delaying the election
and people owe joe biden an apology
excuse me i just face planted my
microphone that's i'm still getting used
to the girth and
length of it um
joe biden said a while ago trump's going
to try to come up with some excuse to
delay the election
um and all these right wingers said he's
crazy this is
there's no evidence and of course you
know we started to see it coming and
case in point this morning donald trump
with universal mail in voting not
absentee which is good by the way
what we're talking about for november is
just expanding absentee trump is trying
to pretend that there's this line in the
sand between absentee and malin
for this november we're just talking
about expanding absentee
2020 will be the most inaccurate and
fraudulent election in history now right
away
if you're not sure you're going to lose
by fair means you don't go out of your
way to deal legitimately delegitimize
the election okay
and then he says it will be a great
embarrassment to the usa the
embarrassment would be if trump gets
reelected and then
says delay the election until people can
properly
securely and safely vote now if it's
safe for
millions or tens of millions of kids as
well as their teachers to spend eight
hours a day in school
how is it unsafe to just have an
election particularly when a lot of the
election will be vote by mail
now whether trump has the power to do
this
is a different question um every
indication is that
he cannot mike pompeo was asked about
this today
and here's what he had to say he
essentially said it's not up to him but
maybe william barr
the justice department will decide
hold on a second i can tell that you
can't hear that let me make sure before
i've done like
10 minutes of stream without anybody
hearing it so this time i'm fixing it
there we go let's take it from the top
the president sent out a tweet that said
quote delay the election until people
can properly securely and safely vote
question marks not saying it will happen
but raising a question
can a president delay the november
presidential election mr secretary
and senator i'm not going to enter a
legal judgment on that
on the fly this morning mr secretary
it's not really on the fly it's like you
know this is one of the key things that
that we do we have elections federal
elections have never been delayed
and can the president do it it's not on
the fly you are an
honors graduate of west point you
are a graduate of the harvard law school
you were on the harvard law review
i was at harvard law school and i went
to a lot of red sox games i went on the
harvard law review
you were very kind you were one of the
most highly trained look at the smug
grin on this clown
and accomplished
lawyers who are part of this
administration
can a president delay a presidential
election senator the
the the in the end the department of
justice others will
will make that legal determination the
department of justice
trump's attorney general william barr
ultimately will decide as far as mike
pompeo is concerned
will there be an election now of course
there's a bunch of legal stuff going on
here and we we can't possibly cover it
all today as we are standing by for
donald trump and and certainly
trump deserves to be asked many
questions about this tweet
um the the the reality is
if no new president is selected if
there's no election
um we actually would be looking at
uh patrick leahy the senate pro
temp who would become president and you
have to go and i i mis
misstated earlier on the show and was
corrected by producer pat ford
in in a moment of infinite wisdom by him
that it wouldn't really go
to the speaker of the house because nan
if the election is canceled nancy
pelosi's reelection would also be
cancelled
so you would have to look at who in the
senate does not depend on being
re-elected
in november it would be the two-thirds
of senators
that are not up for re-election and
therefore patrick leahy becomes the
president
so the idea of not doing the election at
a certain point trump would no longer be
president
but also 32 percent gdp decline
herman cain went to trump's tulsa rally
didn't wear a mask died of covid today
um trump jealous that he's not part of
john lewis's funeral
and the attention is on obama and george
w bush
i mean he's on tilt he's on tilt so uh
we are going to uh
very very soon see what is on the agenda
today and he should be asked about
delaying the election he should be asked
about herman cain he should be asked
about all of these things and it's going
to get
it's going to get crazy is my prediction
so i'm glad that you are joining me
uh youtube chat is on if it doesn't seem
to be on for you just refresh
but youtube chat is happening twitch
chat is happening chat is happening
everywhere my friends
a few super chats coming in let's see
what we've got here
jake says hoping for a nasty question
about herman cain's passing yes as i
mentioned
uh emmanuel kant says congratulations on
nine hundred thousand next stop
surpassing cedars show
i you know i don't i'm not even sure how
many subscribers sam has i know we're
all pretty close but yeah we we
surpassed 900 000 youtube
subscribers about a day and a half ago
we're now at 903
000 we are only 96 000 and change
subscribers away from a million my
goal uh was to get to the million
before election day and it's going to be
very very tight
and um there's this tool on socialblade
which i'm i'm pulling up for you here
which actually
gives you a projection a subscriber
milestone projection
it was january 9th a couple of days ago
let's see if it's been updated at all
um currently looking at
uh july i'm sorry january 6th that went
from january 9th to january 6. so
we've moved it up three days and we've
got to move it up two more months in
order to make it
to a million before the election but it
could happen it very very much could
happen so that's an exciting thing
i want to say thanks to perturbo for
supporting over on twitch
double r rhino has subscribed for nine
months
with prime and spectre has also
subscribed with prime as
has fancy moco fancy moko extremely
extremely exciting
unknown prodigy says do you have any
merch with your signature on it no we've
actually shut down merch sales
it was becoming a customer service
nightmare something weird down here um
it was becoming a customer service
nightmare because of the coronavirus
it was taking forever to produce the the
apparel
and the mugs and then it was things were
taking two months to ship
things were getting lost so for the time
uh being
we have shut down all apparel
and elements of the show promotional
elements of the show
thanks to jody bundrick for grabbing a
youtube subscription pair tier and says
sorry poke you while being awake
i never know what pair's talking about
adian says could trump shut down
government to stop the election
probably not probably not waffles
giroffel says you look a lot like ro
khanna are you twins yeah
i'm guessing you're right yeah that's
good i'm guessing you're referring to
when donald trump told
a black a young black reporter that he
looked like 80 year old jewish man
michael bloomberg
two days ago that was a weird moment c
asks do you i think trumpists may riot
if trump loses
yeah i'm concerned about that matt
chavez says delaying election tweet is a
distraction from gdp
certainly a possibility certainly trump
may well know he can't delay the
election but he knows
it will get attention it'll take
attention away from the worst
gdp numbers ever and that absolutely may
be uh behind
what he did let me say thank you to
michael turner who's new member number
one today on my website joinedpakman.com
robin sattler is new member number two
and justin philhauer or fillower
is new member number three today at
joinedpakman.com very much appreciate
that support
i do have oh people are asking about
bingo
let's see if it looks like we it looks
like we still have some time
i do have an updated bingo card there's
only been one
um square that has been changed so far
so let me tell you what's on david
pakman's show bingo right now
the phrase elements of blank is on there
my catchphrase can you imagine remains
on there
caller asking is that me and me saying
yes it is
remains accidentally hitting the
microphone is on there and i i just did
that
me offering an absurd possibly illegal
membership discount
absolutely stays on here and i may offer
one to you just momentarily
a caller sounds as if they're under
water that's like a key component
if if we don't get callers that sound
underwater it's not really the david
pakman show
i tell a story about a current or former
producer i mention my garden
and i mentioned specifically my kukes or
my zooks
i've got another 10 inch zook out there
almost ready to go
i made a delightful um italian granny
recipe
zucchini soup with my first um
my first 10 incher and then i've got
another one out there
my cukes are growing everything's going
crazy me mentioning being from argentina
is a great one i think a lot of people
enjoy that one when it comes up
um from the standpoint of blank i state
or espouse an opinion unpopular with
progressives
i use the phrase peace and love i use
the term weaponized to describe you know
weaponized ignorance or whatever
i use the phrase exactly as we predicted
on the show hey listen
i used that today exactly as i predicted
on the show
months ago donald trump is now floating
the idea
of delaying the election i run my
fingers through my hair yep that happens
i use a click baity youtube title that's
essentially daily
a caller sounds like they're either
exercising or using heavy machinery
during the phone call very very common
i mentioned that massachusetts is
handling the virus well
unfortunately we had a bunch of cases
yesterday and i'm getting very very
worried
that some that we're going in the wrong
direction
i make a hard sell membership pitch i
deliberately pronounce a name
incorrectly i run down my personal stock
report
this is a new square we've added by
popular demand i refer to
the streamer often known as destiny or
omni destiny
as stephen kenneth destiny bonnell the
second
a caller drops call i use the phrase
shot out of a cannon or i mentioned
going to a cafe or coffee shop so this
is the bingo card as of right now
if anybody has an element here that they
believe should be removed
uh get in touch with with me via my
website contact form
and tell me what should replace it but i
think that that is um
it's it's a very very solid uh bingo
card
at least for the time being
we are standing by for a very suddenly
called press conference by president
donald trump where he will no doubt be
asked
i hope about suggesting delaying the
election it looks like we are about to
go live now
a live stream starting soon over here
and
uh we appear to be i think this is fox
news's john roberts here
and other people are filing in and it
looks like this may start very
very soon i want to say thanks to our
crews for subscribing with twitch prime
as well as old
salty crab very much appreciate that
and b gamer boy i guess
and bilbo blazens and i couldn't forget
the mushroom man
all supporting over on twitch getting us
now almost to a level three
hype train i do want to let me do a an
absurd possibly a legal membership
discount i do want to remind everybody
our primary funding source the
consistent funding source
is people who grab a membership on
joinpakman.com
i try to be a good employer we
uh i try to provide you know good
working conditions for everybody
we do health care we do i'm launching
retirement for for employees and
um all that we do show wise
paying for studio equipment etc
everything happens thanks to support
via membership so if you have lost your
job
due to covet you know what i'm talking
about right
you know what i'm talking about uh or
whatever i don't want your last dollar
or two but
if you can throw a dollar 80 a month at
us or two bucks a month
grab a membership at joinedpakman.com
use the coupon code
2020 now i see people signing up i will
thank all of you for example
veronica rivera is new member number
four that's exciting
peter horrex is new member number five
lauren connell is new member number six
these are
real people okay this is not you know
fraudulent or mailed in in any way these
are real people signing up and it's uh
tremendous so
uh that being said let's proceed
oh also thanks to konana ambassador
and bim formed welsh john
mahew.exe and gold child
all of whom are signing up over on
twitch and
yes for people ask okay this is a really
good beautiful i love this question
if you use the coupon code when does the
price go up
okay are you ready for this never
never when you institute a membership
discount
the price never goes up if you decide
financial circumstances improve in the
future you want to go from two to six
bucks a month
have at it okay the price never goes up
this is not some low low introductory
rate or the stuff you see
you know uh uh you know um get your
first one for
just pay shipping and handling and then
all of a sudden you're getting dinged 30
40 50
the answer is never it's the low low
price forever
um okay
if you're just joining us you've not
missed anything yet we uh we're waiting
for donald trump at the bottom of the
hour
we've got a level four hype train
happening on twitch
we have 20 000 people watching on
youtube which is insane
i have super chats coming in um what
else here
pair is sending strange chats uh
dixie wreck it says on celeb heights
you're officially listed at five
six are you kidding me users have
submitted damning photos that support
the listed height
i am not five six i'm five eight celeb
heights david pakman is that real
let me see here
i'm not even finding that as a real
website so i don't know if you're
trolling me
but no i am not uh i am not
six yeah that's not even a website i'm
able to find so certainly not
okay cj atonielle says i really don't
believe that they're cooking the coveted
books because there are numerous
third-party sources who gather their
information independent of hhs
that is a complicate that's a complex
discussion
which requires significantly more detail
than we can go into right now but we're
examining all of the information
bae photo asks do you think he'll take
questions today i'm doubtful if
if trump does not take questions today
i'll destroy my new microphone he must
take questions today
lauren connell has signed up on youtube
jacob ratner
well where did that go jacob ratner
when a bunch of these come in at once
it'll scroll where did jacob ratner go
jacob ratner says now with suspending
the election and troops in portland
is it accurate to describe trump as
fascist listen
he's a wild desperate authoritarian
is he a fascist i mean he he's not a
fascist in practice
but he certainly has fascist tendencies
um
[Music]
okay we have we have hit a level five
hype train
on twitch uh the best performance we've
ever had
is 620 percent level five right now
we're at 44 percent level five
the best we've gotten is 620 and we'll
see
if we can do that today please remember
if you are just joining us over on
youtube
we are in a very very heated race to 1
million subscribers and we're 96
000 away we surpassed 900 000
two days ago we're now at 903 almost 904
so if you have no idea who i am and
you'd prefer i shut up
well it is my channel but if you're just
coming through for the trump press
briefing
please hit that subscribe button you'll
be notified of future streams
it's free completely and totally free
and we are trying to get to a million
subscribers before
election day if you're watching on
twitch where 50 000 is our goal in the
immediate it's
certainly a much more modest goal but a
beautiful goal nonetheless
um let's see here jfk pair keep sending
super chats and i don't get them
jf gambi says david greetings from
france
frus what's trump's hold my beer speech
today i
i have no idea what to expect today
quite quite frankly
um bunch of emojis coming in adidia
dakshinamurthy dash keenum
murthy yes has subscribed on youtube
frolfganger says president pro-tempore
of the us senate is currently iowa
republican chuck grassley not leahy
right but here's the thing
if because republicans have more seats
to defend
if the november elections don't happen
that third
is open meaning you go based on the
other 65 senators
the majority of those are democrats
meaning it goes to leahy that's my
understanding
okay that's that's the math of it uh ben
brooks says hope you're well david what
is pres presidential directive 51 i
don't remember
that that's something that's come up
before and i i don't i'd have to look it
up i don't remember offhand
we have about 90 seconds to achieve a
full hype train we want to complete the
act if possible
and we have done it thanks to flat face
for families prime subscription we have
achieved
a complete level five hype train
uh kevin altschuler says i was a student
of yours at bc can i ask you
uh why you talked about boobies so much
in class right okay
uh i i can assure you if that was the
case there would have been uh some kind
of public scandal about it for sure
thanks to eric broski broski
for the super chat wgo ettrick says you
might have extra time
to get a million if trump postpones the
elections congratulations to your family
i've got a problem with my earpiece here
what's going on with it
seems to have been deformed in some
weird way i wonder if my ear canal had
an issue there
uh make it simple says any thoughts on
creating a pacman college yes i'm
against it
sounds scammy thomas reich says did you
think that president trump is just
taking your attention away from the bad
economic numbers that came out today
yeah i mentioned that earlier and that
certainly is uh plausible
chris r says do you think kamala as vp
would equal low turnout for biden
kyle's show talk against kamala he seems
counterproductive to get dt out
um i'm not
sure i completely understand i favor
warren
but i think that really harris
warren um i i don't think it's going to
make a big impact and quite frankly
i don't care either way it's very clear
what we need to do in november
ziggy stardust says david please
recommend a good book or books on
introductions to economics introductions
are tough i mean i
recently read um angus deaton's
second to last book it's not really an
introduction to economics i want to be
careful with those recommendations
because
um because i don't feel
super confident about any particular
intro to econ book quite frankly
timothy says david could you say
something quick about how bad the gdp
issue is for the country please yeah we
talked about that on the broadcast show
today and we'll continue tomorrow and
i've done a lot of gdp
stuff lately so check out some of that
amplitude
says do people recognize you in public
often if so what's the weirdest thing
that's ever happened
nothing super weird has happened last
time i was in london in december
i was walking down some random place in
london
and a guy came up to me and said are you
david pakman and he and i said yeah
where are you from he's like i'm
actually from canada so a canadian
viewer ran into me in london
we were both a little bit weirded out i
guess but it wasn't particularly odd
um in estonia i was recognized there
were some americans an american couple
that was vacationing in estonia
and they said hello at a great
sort of like uh not a farmer's market it
was kind of like a
food stall uh place
or something um that was that was
different
baron steuben says congrats on your
first 10-incher yeah i had a beautiful
zucchini in my garden last week turned
it into zucchini soup
and it was really great joseph spaconi
says
senate pro tem is chuck grassley yeah
okay so i just explained
that momentarily uh tristan mccoppen
says corporate media have greatly
underestimated the seriousness of
trump's comment
always responds saying he can't and said
the same thing about everything else
yeah i think we have to take it
seriously i don't believe it's likely
but when you just ignore it's sort of
like hey just ignore extremists
and pretend they don't exist yeah well
then their ideas are less
uh less um they become mainstreamed and
it's a huge problem for us so i've never
subscribed to that
idea i think we seriously need to be if
trump says it let's take him at his word
you know
he's thinking about how could he delay
the election
um shea smith says i think now listen
should be on the bingo card that's not a
bad
submission uh jr says i swear your
sarcastic remarks and facial reactions
during these conferences make me laugh
each and every time and god knows how
much i need this
at this strange time thank you i'm glad
to be here
mike henderson has grabbed an alpha
membership adidia
dakshinamorthy says a tangent from
herman cain
your thoughts on thomas sowell maybe do
a video on him i can't seem to find
anyone arguing against his views
i actually think if if you want to if
you want a um
if you want a right-wing economist that
is intelligent and will make you think
he may not change your mind but he will
make you think thomas sowell is an
interesting guy to check out and his
book basic economics certainly lays out
sort of like the
uh traditional orthodoxy of um
standard economic theory as taught in
you know places like northwestern et
cetera
and i think it's worth checking out for
sure
let me say a few twitch thank yous as we
wait for the mango menace
right now kill ruthie kilrothy has
subscribed with prime
paperclip maximizer has subscribed with
prime
and so has mr dreadnought as well as
let's hug bro
not during the virus right but but
sometime soon
let me say thanks to some new website
members these are really great people
olay shell is new member number seven
today
conor easter day is new member number
eight
amber wade number nine
uh jordan jennings great to see you new
member number ten
um anthony delacio mike o'brien
oliver marisol and uh oh i think that's
it those are the three
are numbers 11 12 and 13.
also want to say thanks to nathaniel
davidson who's new member number 14.
ramona rivas is number 15.
michael emig and diana heffernan are
numbers
16 and 17 and then clinton kenyon
neil wood david hannah and justin small
get us to 21. wow
wow huge day
big big things going on as we await
donald trump here
some adjustments made to the flags i
guess kind of strange
what else do we got here bacon lover
says the scratchy phone line is on
purpose to disrupt and
disrupt and dissuade listeners of your
show this is silence
opposition 101 common in china hashtag
deep state hates dp you know you're
making a lot of sense i have to say
thanks to brandy macgoff ali mack dilsad
moraler for subscribing on youtube
joseph van scoy says david sorry new
mike
still getting used to the length and
girth michael scott that's what she
said yeah i we had a couple of tough
days with the new microphone but
multiple audio engineers have been
coaching me
through tweaking the settings i think
the show right now sounds as good as it
has in a long time
um now here oh here's donald trump here
we go this is going to be brutal my
friends we're going to switch over to
the c-span feed this is a better feed
it'll be 10 seconds delayed but trust me
this is a better feed for us
standing by now for donald trump
and uh
and he comes momentarily
okay maybe it's more like a 30-second
delay but this is a this is a better
stream here we go
[Music]
thank you very much buckle up folks
let me begin by expressing our sadness
at the passing of
a wonderful man and a dear friend of
mine herman cain
he was a very special person i got to
know him very well
[Music]
and unfortunately he passed away from a
thing called the china virus
and we send our prayers to any mention
of him catching it at your tulsa rally
gloria
wonderful family and i have to say
america grieves for all of the 150
000 americans who
had their lives taken by this
horrible invisible enemy we mourn their
loss
as a nation we mourn their loss
as people as people that love one
another
and we're working very hard
to not only contain
this horrible event this horrible plague
it's what it is is a plague but also to
come up with therapeutics and vaccines
and we're making a lot of strides
all over the world they're having
tremendous problems resurgence
has taken place in many countries that
people thought were doing well
despite a wide range of approaches to
the pandemic between
countries this resurgence in cases is
occurring
throughout large portions
of our planet in japan china
australia belgium spain france to a much
smaller degree it's important to
understand and they're immediately
locking back up
it came back and in a couple of cases
came back very strongly
the virus was said to be under control
but new cases have
risen very significantly once again
he seems to be trying to argue he's
better because other countries are
seeing resurgences
your decision on that you have to hold
your statement since the beginning of
june daily new cases
have increased by a factor of 14 times
in
israel 35 times
that's 35 times in japan and nearly 30
times in australia just to name a few
this is also deceptive because when you
have almost no cases any increase is
going to be on a percentage basis very
high i mean this is very very deceptive
i'm sure you know
latin america now leads the world in
confirmed infections
and with the scarcity of testing in
latin america the true numbers you have
no idea what they might be so he's
grouping together like 20 countries to
say they have more than we do just
anywhere except for our country
this disease is highly contagious and
presents unique challenges to
challenges our border states meanwhile
states like california
washington state maryland virginia
nevada
illinois oregon and many others they
were thought to be doing well and they
had
a big resurgence and were hit very hard
and governors that were extremely
popular
are not so popular anymore they were
held up as models to follow and
then they got hit and i'm not even
saying it's their fault it's probably
not their fault
it's just the way it is that's the way
it is
highly infectious one of the most
infectious
diseases that anybody has ever seen
that's not true the art the are
the reproduction rate is actually not
that high for coronavirus but who cares
what the facts are right
like what we're witnessing now
but these states have also seen the
virus substantially
rebound and again no one is immune
no one is immune these facts
illustrate the imposing
[Music]
determinant he seems to be having a
problem speaking anybody notice it
a blanket shutdown to achieve a
temporary reduction
in cases is certainly not a viable
long-term strategy for any country
people are starting to understand the
disease now strategy we certainly
have understood a lot about the disease
that we didn't have any idea we didn't
nobody ever saw anything like this the
primary purpose of a
shutdown was to flatten the curve ensure
sufficient
hospital capacity and develop effective
treatments and
therapies to reduce mortality
and we've done that but it can come
rearing back
when you least suspect it
we did the right thing initially we
saved millions of lives
what we did did the right thing now it's
millions okay
but a permanent shutdown
would no longer be the answer at all
a small ship because no one proposed a
permanent shutdown we don't want to do
that
small shutdowns can be very helpful
but not for long periods of time we
understand what we're dealing with now
but it's a very complex situation
and i can only say thank evan that we
that we are so advanced in what we're
doing in terms of
vaccines and therapies what we now know
a great deal about the virus and how to
treat it
and who it targets almost half of the
deaths come from
less than one percent of our population
think of it half of the deaths
he doesn't understand the status that
tremendous number half of the deaths
come from
less than one percent of our population
is living in nursing homes
and assisted living facilities the
average age of those who die
from the illness is 78.
we've announced very strong measures to
protect those who are
most vulnerable the scientific path
forward is to
protect those at highest risk while
allowing those at lower risk to
carefully return to work and to school
with appropriate precautions
i'm once again urging the american
people to protect their
dear family and friends and anybody
who's
elderly especially if somebody's elderly
and they have
heart problems if they have
certain illnesses diabetes is
a very bad one having to do with what
we're discussing
but you want to protect the elderly and
socially distance
wear a mask if you cannot socially
distance and practice
vigorous hygiene vigorously everyone
even healthy young people should be
taking extraordinary care to avoid
infecting those at the highest risk
from this terrible disease the elderly
and those with chronic
health issues have to be protected in
the current hot spots across the sun
belt
the data is showing very encouraging
signs arizona in particular has crossed
an important threshold that's the place
you want to be
every person with a virus we're now
seeing an average of less than
one additional person infected and the
numbers are coming down and coming down
very substantially
they're starting to come down in florida
arizona is really leading away i was in
texas yesterday and they're starting to
come down
significantly we believe in texas i need
another few days to figure that one out
but it looks like they're coming down
very significantly
earlier today i visited the red cross
headquarters
to discuss plasma therapy which is
plasma there it is again
tremendous uh plus a tremendous thing
that they're looking at
and they have a lot of experience why
why why potentially life-saving
treatments that infuse
sick patients with powerful antibodies
donated by those who have recovered
successfully from this disease more than
two million americans have recovered
from the virus and today
we're asking them to visit
coronavirus.gov
coronavirus.gov and volunteer to donate
plasma we need plasma it's something
that's been
very effective and we need plasma from
those that were
infected and successfully recovered
as most people do most people do
plasma is one of the many promising
treatments my administration is
accelerating
oh my goodness we've secured over 90
percent of the world's supply of
rem deciver rem disavar which is
terrific
and encouraging a thousand times how
could he still be getting it wrong
effectively block replication of the
virus
we've also approved the use of the
widely available
steroid which has been very successful
dexamethasone
okay which has shown success even in
patients at more advanced stages of the
disease
how did he say it we announced a 450
million dollar agreement with
regeneron to build manufacturing
plants and hundreds of thousands of
doses of
its antibody treatment which is
currently in late stage
clinical trials moving along very
rapidly that's regeneron
as a result of such significant strides
and
treatment the mortality rate in those
over the age of
18 is 85 lower
than it was just in april so in a very
short period of time
think of that at just 18 85 percent
lower than it was in april
big statement now i want to provide an
update
on our efforts to ensure a strong
economic comeback
including our negotiations on capitol
hill
throughout this crisis my administration
has taken the most aggressive action in
history to
rescue american workers we love our
american workers
and we've set records on job creation
records
two months in a row we enacted a
three trillion dollar economic relief
package
the paycheck protection program alone
saved over 50 million jobs
we delivered 300 billion dollars to
direct cash payments to americans
we approved 500 billion dollars for our
hardest hit
industries 500 billion dollars
we allowed struggling homeowners to
reduce or defer their mortgage payments
and we put a nationwide moratorium on
evictions from federally backed
properties
it's a big thing very big thing industry
we also suspended student loan payments
for six months and we're looking to do
that
additionally and for additional periods
of time this is the worst it's ever been
i think
as a result of these extraordinary steps
by
the administration we added a record
seven million jobs
in the two months passed alone
to ensure this comeback continues
which we think it will the human
devastation is
is unconscionable but aren't we all
going to miss plasma
and rim disavar when it's over we were
outdoing everybody from
china if you remember for many years you
heard that in
2019 china would surpass the united
states well
we're not going to miss it okay got it
gained on them very
significantly we took it to a level that
nobody's ever seen
2019. and we'll be back there very
shortly it won't take very long
based on everything that we're seeing
it's not going to take very long i think
next year is going to be an excellent
year maybe one of our best years
hopefully with a different president an
economic standpoint yeah
we can never ever forget the
people that have been lost and we never
will we'll never forget them
never forget what happened this could
have been stopped in china they should
have stopped it
and they didn't but i'm asking congress
to pass additional legislation to
support americans in need
first we want a temporary extension of
expanded
unemployment benefits this will provide
a critical bridge for
americans who lost their jobs to the
pandemic
through no fault of their own this was
not anybody's fault
from the standpoint of jobs it happened
terrible thing happened could have been
stopped it happened
i want to thank senate republicans for
fighting to
extend unemployment benefits today and
the face of very strong democrat
obstruction which i'm surprised at
because this is great for our country
and it's great for our workers and it
wasn't our workers fault
second we're asking democrats to work
with us to find a solution
that will temporarily stop evictions
we do not want people who have lost
their jobs due to the virus to be
evicted from their home
remember that a whole bunch of governors
are already on this and they've extended
the eviction moratorium
you know he's working to pass additional
economic relief payments for american
citizens
american like the payments sent directly
to
160 million americans earlier this year
which was a tremendously successful
program
this money will help millions of
hard-working families get by my
administration is also asking democrats
to work with us to pass
105 billion dollars to help schools
safely reopen
children are not at the lowest
risk if you look at what's going on the
younger the better
amazing the immune system for children
the lower
they are in age the lower the risk in
terms of the age group itself
i tell the story that in new jersey with
thousands
and thousands of people dying sadly
dying
the governor was telling me that only
one
phil murphy only one died under the age
of 18. you can tell that somebody has
told him anytime you refer to deaths
you've got to throw in like that it's
tragic and you can tell that
it's not natural you know he'll say and
then he'll say and then these are tragic
deaths and we're sad about this
the lowest risk of any age group from
the virus
indefinite school closures will inflict
lasting harm
to our nation's children we must follow
the science and get students safely back
to
school while protecting children
teachers staff
and family we have to remember that
there's another side to this keeping
them out of school
and keeping work close is causing death
also
economic harm but causing death for
different reasons but death
probably more death if governors do not
want to
open the public schools the money should
go to parents
so they can send their children to the
school of their choice so
we say if a school doesn't want to open
or have a governor this is one of his
craziest ideas someone like start
cutting checks to parents who are
keeping their kids home i mean it's just
wild
of that going on the money should go to
the parents
so they can send their children to the
school of their choice
if schools stay closed the money should
follow the students so families are in
control of decisions about their
sons and daughters about their children
but to pass a bill democrats must reject
the extreme partisan voices in their
party
they have tremendous voices they're
looking at november third
tremendous points and probably a day
later they'll say let's open up the
country
but the democrats have to reject the
extreme partisan voices in their party
so that wow
we can get our country going even
quicker than it's going right now we
have a lot opening
and we have a lot of states that
you thought were doing pretty poorly
from the standpoint of the virus and are
actually coming back very strong
this pandemic has underscored the
importance of economic policies
that put american families and workers
first
i got elected on the fact that i put
america first
for many many decades in my opinion we
put america last
if you look at the crazy horrible
disgraceful trade deals that we've
oh no watched for many years destroy our
country
after we terminated it we have usmca now
which is a great deal and our farmers
are doing
really well despite the pandemic the
farmers are desperate
but we put america first america's
families first
and america's workers first but that
means bringing jobs and factories back
to our shores reducing unnecessary
regulations and creating
new training opportunities for jobs and
for the future we've cut regulations at
a level that no president has ever cut
regulations
meaningless claims and we've cut taxes
more than any president
in the history of our country americans
always rise to the challenge and we will
emerge more resilient
more self-reliant more independent and
more prosperous than ever before
so i just want to thank you all and if
you'd like we'll take a few here we go
steve please are you going to launch an
effort to try to delay the act of the
election or was that just a trial
balloon this morning
well what i want to explain to people
but it doesn't need
much explanation i mean you look at
article after article new york's male
vote
tens of thousands of mail ballots have
been tossed out
in this year's primaries what will
happen in november it's a mess
this is done by washington post can you
believe the washington post of
wallpapers
fake news but in this case it's not fake
it's true convenient so no this is done
by the wall street journal
here's another one vote by mail
experiment reveals potential problems
within postal voting system ahead in
the november remember that our in-person
voting system is also a mess right so so
it's like that that's never mentioned
either
trial runs are a disaster and
i don't want to see an election you know
so many years i've been watching
elections
and they say the projected winner or the
winner of the election
i don't want to see that take place in a
week
after november third or a month or
frankly with litigation and everything
else that can happen
years years or you never even know
who won the election will never get
results hundreds of millions
of universal mail-in
ballots hundreds of millions where are
they going who are they being sent to
what it's common sense you don't have to
know anything about politics
and the democrats 120 to 130 million
people usually vote hundreds of millions
what want to see i want an election and
a result
much much more than you i think we're
doing very well we have the same
fake polls but we have real polls we're
doing very well i just left texas
oh my god and
biden came out against fracking well
that means texas is
that's great we don't want to be one of
the most unemployed
states in our country that means
oklahoma north dakota is he running on
fracking now
going to be a disaster ohio pennsylvania
disaster
no fracking biden's crushing
pennsylvania right now election
i don't want to be waiting around for
weeks and
and months and literally potentially if
you really did it right
years because you're the problem
fracking or vote by mail like it's not
even clear
you saw paterson new jersey you saw many
other instances
there's tremendous litigation on that
right now
and that doesn't include absentee
absentee is different absentee you have
to
that's a lie and you have to send in for
free
go through a whole procedure it's just
expanded absentee that's all it is in
november guys
in florida because i'm in washington i'm
at the white house so
i'll be an absentee voter we have a lot
of absentee voters and it works so we're
in favor of absentee but it's much
different that's what everybody's doing
and
millions of people in california they're
going to send out tens
of millions of voting forms well where
are they going to go
you read where postmen are in big
trouble now
you read where city councils are in big
trouble now voter fraud
all over the uh
no i want to get i want to be standing
hopefully
someone should ask to what date do you
want to delay it victory
because we're doing things with our
country that i think nobody else could
have done
our country is despite this pandemic
which is
devastating the rest of the world by the
way devastating
one of the the articles that came out
was
the world's coveted resurgence this is a
verbal inkblot
the main editorial yesterday in the wall
street journal i don't always agree with
him what's he talking about they have
the world's
coveted resurgence countries hailed as
models to see and then they go
the virus returns you can't even read it
at a level like it's never they haven't
even seen
we've been giving praise to certain
countries and the virus has now come to
them like
remember the question was vote delaying
the election very interesting and it
talks about many countries where
everybody was holding them up and saying
what a great job they did
well it's just one of those things
didn't work out so well
so we want to have
an election on what date i'd love to see
voter id
oh god but this is the opposite of voter
id oh my god the democrats love it the
republicans hate it
we all agree he's lost the country has
never seen anything like this it really
it's really unprecedented will lead to
the greatest fraud
you know we talk about russia russia
russia two and a half years and then
they found nothing and there was nothing
but they talk russia russia russia they
talk china
they talk all of these countries they
say they get involved in our elections
this is easy you can forge ballots
this is much easier for foreign
countries go ahead
in the election it's probably a
non-starter wouldn't you agree with that
i i just feel i don't want to delay
i want to have the election but i also
don't want to have to wait for three
months and then find out that the
ballots are all missing he doesn't want
to wait
so his idea is to delay anybody
understand how crazy that is common
sense
and everyone knows it smart people know
it
stupid people may not know it and some
people don't want to talk about it
but they know it and no we want to have
an election
where people actually go in and what's
your name my name is so-and-so
boom you signed the book like i've been
doing for years that's the way it works
it's very very unfair to our country if
they do this our country will be a
laughingstock all over the world
the president is suggesting we delay an
election ladies and gentlemen
california's exit 28 million or some
massive number
other states are sending out millions
and millions of ballots
well they've done it they had
experiments they had
news organizations experimenting and
look read the story in the washington
post about
mail-in voting it's a disaster i'm very
surprised to see that story
frankly from them the story is a
disaster
so we're asking for a lot of trouble and
uh
no do i want to see a date change no but
i don't want to see a crooked election
this
election will be the most rigged
election in history
if that happens june so mr president you
said that you
don't want to see a delay in the
election
but then it looks like the process of
these mail-in ballots is going to
continue to november
well we have many court cases jim we
have one that's been filed for a while
now in
western pennsylvania as an example on
mail-in ballots and
by we give tremendous examples numbers
of examples of all the fraud
and all of the things that have taken
place with respect to male imbalance
the net effect of what you tweeted this
morning and what you're talking about
now
to cast doubt on the results of the
november 3rd well it's had an
interesting impact
i didn't know it was going to be yeah
people think you're not the impact it
had what people are now looking at
is am i right but not me are all these
stories right about
the fact that these elections will be
fraudulent
they'll be fixed they'll be rigged and
everyone's looking at it and a lot of
people are saying you know that probably
will
remember guys he still hasn't accepted
the 2016 election break the log jam
in congress and to prevent that
unemployment
insurance from lapsing what do you plan
to put on the table every question
it's a great question i can't tell you
though because that wouldn't be very
smart
from a negotiating standpoint but we'll
be putting certain things on the table
we want to get money to people it wasn't
there for money to people and we want to
get money to people
and it has to be substantial it's not
their fault what happened
the fact is people don't like saying it
they know it's true
it's china's fault okay china it's not
their fault
it's not the worker who lost his job
it's china's fault
and that's the way it is uh oan place
uh-oh yesterday dhs came to an agreement
with the governor of oregon to remove
federal officers of oregon state
troopers took over
mayor ted miller was noticeably absent
from that agreement
are you confident sir that the state of
oregon will be able to quell the
protests in portland
and if the violence does continue would
you consider redeploying federal troops
so our people have done homeland
security have done a fantastic job they
went to oregon
a little more than a week ago the place
was a mess
the city portland was just a disaster
uh you see it and a lot of people
weren't reporting it right they tried to
pretend it was a protest as opposed to
anarchists and agitators you understand
what i'm saying oh she knows a
mess short while ago
and they saved a federal courthouse that
costs hundreds of millions of dollars
and they put a ring around the
courthouse and they saved it but
the group that's there is basically
meant to save buildings and they were
very strong
very powerful and they didn't come out
too often out of this cocoon that they
built in order to save these very
expensive valuable and psychologically
important buildings right like
courthouses a psychologically important
building
we've been dealing with them and
we think they don't know what they're
doing
because this should not have been going
on for 60 days
that's not our job unless in case of him
three days ago he said it was 51 days
that was a lie now he says it's 60. not
our job to go in and
clean out the cities that's supposed to
be done by local law enforcement
yesterday the governor worked a deal
where they'll do it
we'll stand by they'll do it and that's
good that was very good but she didn't
report it that way
what she reported was totally different
she said i think trump wants to take
over the country
it's crazy so what happened is our
people are staying there
to see whether or not they can do it
today and tomorrow and if they don't do
it we will
send in the national guard and we'll
take care of it and we're telling right
now these protesters and many should be
arrested
because these are professional agitators
these are professional anarchists these
are people that hate our country
we're telling them right now that we're
coming in very soon the national guard a
lot of people
so you went in you're coming out but
you're gonna stand there aside and then
warn you're coming back okay got it
save it these are people that are
allowed to go forward and do what they
have to do
and i think that makes the governor's
job and the mayor's job a lot easier
so they're working today and probably
tomorrow to clean out
uh this beehive of of terrorists
terrorists if they do it i'm going to be
very happy and then slowly we can start
to leave
he's a significant mental illness this
guy is out of his mind sending in the
national
mr trump given given what's happening
with major league baseball and now today
the rutgers football team is quarantined
how can you assure people that schools
will be safely reopened
so can you assure anybody of anything i
do say again
young people are almost immune to this
disease
younger the better i guess they're
stronger they're stronger they have a
stronger immune system it's an
incredible thing nobody's ever seen this
before
various types of flu will hurt young
people more than
older people but young people are
almost immune if you look at the
percentage it's a tiny percent
of so close to total immunity one
percent
so we have to have our schools open
we have to protect our teachers we have
to protect our elderly but we do have to
have our schools
open yeah please
mr president a week ago you said uh
you're in the process of developing a
strategy that's going to be very
powerful
involving the chronovirus where where is
that strategy well i think you're seeing
it and i think you will see it and
you're seeing one of the
things that we've done that we're
getting it hasn't been utilized
we're all set to march when it comes to
the vaccine we have
great therapeutics that are testing very
well
he should pretend to fall down and walk
off incredible companies johnson and
johnson and
pfizer and merck and all of these great
companies and they're doing very well
you're seeing and the delivery system is
all set logistically we have a general
that that's all he does is deliver
things whether it's soldiers or other
shipping clerks okay and i think you're
going to see something that's going to
be spectacular
the fda has approved things at a rate
that's a
tiny fraction of what it would cause
what it would take during a
another administration let's say
you remember in the chris wallace
interview he promised a totally new
health care plan approved within two
weeks
where did that go to deliver them very
very quickly the vaccines are doing well
the therapeutics are doing well and
we're all set to deliver them as soon as
we have them
and that's going to be very soon thank
you very much
you could tell he was going to have to
bail you could just tell he was going to
have to bail because it was going
nowhere
uh this is this is the powerful strategy
he says
um just completely unbelievable i mean
this is a very ill
ill person it's a scared person
it's a desperate person it it it's a
delusional person
it's a narcissistic person um
we've never seen anything like this and
we just have to put an end to it it has
to
an end how somebody has to put an end to
this and we know what this
we know fortunately it's not like hey
you know we've got this really
complicated situation
we've got no ideas we just don't know
how to end this we just vote them out
that's we the the solution is so clear
we just have to do it
um and sometimes you have to spend all
this time
finding a solution we we know the
solution we just vote them out
that's it and we so overwhelmed the vote
that you know it it just the suppression
can't do anything and etc
it's it's stunning what is going on um
if you're on your way out
on youtube please hit that subscribe
button you'll be notified of future
streams
it's free and we're trying to get to a
million subscribers by election day
we're 95 000 away
um so if you're headed out thank you for
stopping by i hope i was not
too bothersome if you were just trying
to see trump's ranting
but please do hit that subscribe button
on the way out
uh 36 000 of you could do some real
damage on the way to
a million same thing applies on twitch
if you're headed out
please do make sure that you are uh
following tomorrow
we may stream there may be a stream
tomorrow
there will be more chess streams coming
up soon there will be if there is a maga
nanny as you know what i'm talking about
press briefing tomorrow
i will absolutely uh cover it for you
but this is th this is not
this is not a dress rehearsal this is
the real thing trump's talking about
let's suspend the election because i
don't want results to take a long time
so then you would delay it which you
would think would
make it take even longer i mean it's
it's wild it's wild what's going on but
this is
absolutely uh no dress rehearsal this is
the real thing
and we've got to get him out we've got
to get him out i'll see everybody
tomorrow
you